what is this strange new world death has
presented us with its Genosha we're back
on the surface I love it it's very
French where oh you signed him a badge
polymer and I thought you were dead man
what the [ __ ] I smell cheap hot sauce
that's my dad fool oh I know you're
around here I like for me for us
whatever we gotta move we need everybody
on this one if we're gonna stop sinister
okay ain't you - yeah duh it's my game
what game serious you quit scratching
your ass bub and get into the fight
uh-huh I love how people know the
weirdest cut scene ever well what the
[ __ ] look at this it looks like oh it's
a sachet what in the hell is going on
here
so I missed a little a little apart I'm
probably gonna add it in somehow but you
didn't miss anything honestly like the
last part we got a hat from the other
parts of it evil [ __ ] no you're not
going [ __ ] what where was I oh she fell
down don't fit [ __ ] I love who's doing
that what are you doing
oh it's [ __ ] head fell off more evil
[ __ ]
whoa what someone say something hey and
thanks that say I'm sorry sorry about
that but honestly would you didn't even
get a hat there's nothing cool in the
hole shut who hello hello everyone
you're in the end of the game though
which makes me a little sad but I'm
curious what the [ __ ] is gonna happen
Osho Osho shot Jace's [ __ ] Christ it's
shower time
yeah
oh that I love the shock yeah I miss
what the [ __ ]
whatever [ __ ] are you doing ads
benchmarking time later yeah I don't
know who complain about the combat in
this game it's [ __ ] awesome
especially now that we have the [ __ ]
lazy again why are we going I know
Oh over here I know no matter yeah I
missed that thing I missed the Twitter
line the pool was a poodle what are you
doing what're you doin here girl water
you don't win it don't try to be a plant
with me okay I don't like plants Peter
Parker [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] eat
maids [ __ ] you guys like momentum hey
snake [ __ ]
come on let me finish him bye
Oh goodbye see you tow
oh it's looking better when you go in
why'd you go in no babe that's what
you've got with your gonna he'll be
etched the combat is awesome I love it I
love the lasers that are the best [ __ ]
ever
oh geez who the [ __ ] is Billy in this
entire game I asked my thumb skip I beli
it's good knowing ya we're going in the
northbound railway okay I'll take it
what is this place ah this time the bike
is that the same bike I bet we're gonna
ride a bike that's like my dream in
every game is you follow me for a while
you know
sinister this way uh-huh it'll be the
real deal this time when we find him
I doubt it that jokes getting pretty old
huh even for high moon oh [ __ ] nice
stuffing uh-huh where are we best
selfing ever was in here oh sweet
we have so many Deadpool points [ __ ]
ridiculous
oh whoa whoa whoa baby baby where were
you the riding winner-winner when the
heavens
and that's how you tell boss battles
pretty good timing can't complain about
it I want to make a cheesy cheesy
one-liners like that Batman thief frost
or rabbit what cue the dinosaur yeah
easy
that's not even what killed them I don't
even whatever I don't know what I'm
talking about oh hey man how you doing
right here just to see you always get to
meet new people
okay I want to show you self kills with
these they're pretty badass
it's [ __ ] Ellie you know when she's
like Ellie style right away I don't
remember what these are called but I'm
gonna call them Forex that's what I
thought they were when I was a kid
it's like Raphael from Tardos hedge
Forest of course I didn't hear that
later noobs penetration you're welcome
Wow I know dad pull too much now I heard
like all these one-liners
okay sell then I don't even know what
that means
penetrate that would make sense of these
what are they doing this [ __ ] jumping
what are you doing that's as Hamas I try
to make him go off the ledge spinning
really work it was no it wasn't what are
you talking about how we're going here
maybe not I just assumed oh okay what
what that we gotta get all of the
Deadpool coins I mean let's be honest
you don't really we don't really need
them but why are you saying that have
you seen your own apartment dude hey
guys
hey stop shouting I'm a friend I swear
to God I I don't have any friends I
guess we're friends isn't that how it
works
oh that was difficult this game takes
skills
yep oh shut oh [ __ ] never mind never
mind I'll don't die sorry okay well
let's just edit that out pets in the
future
edit that okay we got there we go
these guys are annoying if you run out
of ammo
oh this was here all along I'm an idiot
oh well we have it now it's on your
friend I'm a mom Jerry just like that
Jerry Seinfeld guy he's really funny
hey make noises with the baseline punch
line
BAM I'll do one oh man
happy brother out about video games
isn't it funny when developers put
secret rooms I mean why do they put
secret drugs there this is because they
have some secrets my oh my oh my oh my
oh man now
I tried that's the mug unfunny thing
ever
anyway hey I may not hi what are you
doing
say hi to me said it all I was [ __ ]
easy
hey guys I think out KITT yet okay what
is this baby don't hurt me why do they
always say that shut up I'm not gonna
follow you slippery [ __ ] hey and
that's how we dope [ __ ] more laughing
mechanically totally oh oh sorry
how will you do it
I love the puddles that's left shut up
oh god then that's a lot of you I know
you're ahead happy to see me mad jeez
calm down great place to start a new
game come yeah destroy did it by game
floppy disk keyboard unnecessary it's
not necessary for making games the
random thoughts of Deadpool do we have
any dicks watching this ciao
this is the show I don't think it's a
show Oh almost this year are we going
out here I hear rock and roll music it
should be good yes good boy No
are you sad of a [ __ ]
you're scared of eat this bye good night
Oh smash it Mikey
shut the [ __ ] up hell yeah whoa [ __ ] is
his body doing why the hell are we going
yeah
stop shooting me I shoot you what the
hell did I just say what the hell did I
Jason well played Deadpool well play
probably going okay so a lot of a lot of
waiting is really what I'm gonna do
right of a thing killing a man take away
all his gut and all he's ever gonna have
you're totally breaching this door and
killing everyone inside for some
shameless cross-promotion player da da
da da da da ha ha ha
we make a good team me in that pool I
knew it what are you doing
all the sudden our souls became super
awesome
I don't know how Oh books what are you
doing in this game yeah I can actually
shoot them that's awesome they're not
really books but whatever excuse me fade
that oh now you just piss me off
you don't piss me off no you don't give
me back my shouting see these these are
bullets you don't need to tell me that
Deadpool I know that thank you anyway
show the x-men how it's done what the
[ __ ] does that mean what the [ __ ] is
this okay
oh it is gonna be awesome
press space fine yes press Q okay you
can't go without it press e what does
that do Karp lane buddy Wolverine is
that an ET reference press B hi I am two
space Wolverine go huh Jade of course we
need fuel
Oh banana
banana and alcohol oh and the bottle -
why not is that it back to the future
reference and an easy reference that's
[ __ ] awesome how can you not love
this game oh my god were there 20
minutes earlier press you to trick okay
well I'm doing it oh poor guy okay we're
doing over there just a little surprise
for our player when did he do this
what's that surprise for us
can you believe improv Thanks
ah good it's a breakfast of course what
else would be a few moments later what
the [ __ ] is he planning that is get him
yeah it's a c4 I didn't sir this
it's pretty awesome planet but hey ex
pals
I think gee Deadpool is a genius in
design or maybe not hahaha okay Bryce
I'm gonna have to end this episode I
hope you enjoyed watching don't miss the
next episode is probably gonna be the
last one
look like you've enjoyed watching he's
this guy to cover it today and I'll see
in the next one
[Music]